how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and today we finally have some
official news about Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness now although
Doctor Strange has only had one movie to
himself it doesn't feel like that
because he played a major role in
Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame but now he's back to his own
film kind of he's sharing with Wanda but
still and Doctor Strange too is going to
be an extremely important movie for
phase 4 the MCU and the future of the
MCU in general there's a lot of
predictions and a lot of rumors of who
could show up in the film both heroes
and villains everyone from Ghost Rider
to the loominatee to Mephisto to
nightmare but thankfully according to
one particular actor we know at least
one villain that is going to be in
Doctor Strange 2 and a little bit about
the plot so I'll break down everything
that you need to know but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on all things relating to the
MCU and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a Wolverine
a Funko pop all you have to do to enter
subscribe to my channel like this video
and leave a comment down below so if you
didn't think that you would ever see him
again you would be wrong she would tell
Gia 4 has confirmed that Mordo will be
returning for Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness in an interview
with comicbook.com he revealed that he
is going to be returning to multiverse
of madness and when asked about what
he's been doing since the last Doctor
Strange what he's been doing during the
events of Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame he said that all will
be revealed so he's not just coming back
to have sort of a minor role in
multiverse of madness they're going to
dive into what he's been doing all this
time and the last time we left off with
him was at the end of Doctor Strange and
he became a villain
so we know that at the end he was going
after a sorcerer is going to take their
powers away from them and although at
the end of the film he's not necessarily
a villain he's not going about the world
and causing destruction trying to kill
people he will definitely be a problem
for dr. strange and a lot happened
during the events of infinity war and
endgame and Doctor Strange was a big
part of that and he did have a big part
to play in collecting the Infinity
stones Doctor Strange used the time
stone to look forward in time and saw
all the different scenarios and then he
gave the time stone to Thanos and this
is something that Mordo is definitely
going to have a problem with especially
if you consider the fact that the result
of that was time travel and creating
different realities this is exactly the
type of thing that mortal was talking
about in the first Doctor Strange that
they should not be doing and now they're
going to suffer the consequences of what
they've done and this is exactly why
more dough is going to come back it's
called multiverse of madness the
multiverse is going to explode it's
going to be in madness and more that was
going to be one of the problems that dr.
strange is going to have to deal with
dr. strange will most likely try to
bring all of the Infinity stones back
after all and Avengers in game the
ancient one did explain that the
Infinity stones create our flow of time
and now we don't have any Infinity
stones in the main Marvel Universe so
Doctor Strange is most likely going to
try and get them back and this is
probably where more dough is going to
step in now there are definitely going
to be other villains in the film more
dough is not going to be the only
villain especially when you consider
that Wanda aka The Scarlet Witch is
going to be in the film as well which is
most likely going to be another problem
for more dough because Doctor Strange is
going to be teaching her how to develop
her powers which is something he doesn't
want he wants less sorcerers but
originally after the first Doctor
Strange film finished the director and
the writers did revealed that they
wanted nightmare as the next villain
which would make perfect sense he's a
huge Doctor Strange villain but also
Mephisto could be introduced as well and
this could be a very big tie-in between
Doctor Strange and Wanda and again this
is what Mordo had a problem with in the
first Doctor Strange messing with things
and demons that they shouldn't be
messing with and the big question is
what was Mordo doing this entire time
was he simply out there killing the rest
of the sorcerers or perhaps did he go to
a higher power we know that his staff is
the staff of the Living Tribunal so
clearly he knows that the cosmic
entities exist and perhaps he went to
them after the events of dr. strange and
then after the events of infinity war
and endgame and now it's time for dr.
strange to answer to some of these
cosmic entities perhaps even the Living
Tribunal itself after all it was
revealed that in avengers ingame there
was a deleted scene where dr. strange
sent
Thanos to deal with the Living Tribunal
here Thanos would be judged guilty so if
dr. strange knew how to do this an
endgame we could probably bet that Mordo
knew how to do it as well so in
multiverse of madness we could see
Doctor Strange come face to face with
some of these cosmic entities to answer
for what happened during the events of
endgame and infinity war as Mordo said
in the first Doctor Strange film the
bill comes due always no matter what
happens it seems like dr. strange is
going to have to answer in one way or
another for the events of infinity war
and end game but like Chiwetel said all
will be revealed so let me know what do
you think more de was up to this entire
time in the comments down below don't
forget to give this video a like and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU if you
want live updates you can follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
willful off